I have examined maps of the city with
the greatest care yet I've never again
found the Rudo say these maps have not
been modern maps alone for I know that
names change I have on the contrary
delve deeply into all the antiquities of
the place and have personally explored
every region of whatever name which
could possibly answer to the street I
knew as the rue de se but despite all I
have done it remains a humiliating facts
that I cannot find the house the street
or even the locality where during the
last months of my impoverished life as a
student of metaphysics at the University
I heard the music of Erich Xan that my
memory is broken I do not wonder for my
health
physical and mental was gravely
disturbed throughout the period of my
residence in the Rue Doce and I recall
that I took none of my few acquaintances
there but that I cannot find the place
again as both singular and perplexing
for it was within a half hour's walk of
the University and was distinguished by
peculiarities which could hardly be
forgotten by anyone who had been there
I've never met a person who was seen the
Rue des a the rue de se lay across a
dark River bordered by precipitous brick
Blair windowed warehouses and spanned by
a ponderous bridge of dark stone it was
always shadowy along that River as if
the smoke of neighbouring factories shut
out the Sun perpetually the river was
also odorous with evil stenches which i
have never smelled elsewhere and which
may someday help me to find it
since I should recognize them at once
beyond the bridge were narrow cobbled
streets with rails and then came the
ascent at first gradual but incredibly
steep as the Rue Doce was reached
I have never seen another street as
narrow and steep as the Rideau say it
was almost a cliff closed to all
vehicles consisting in several places of
flights of steps and ending at the top
in a lofty ivied wall
it's paving was irregular sometimes
stone slabs sometimes cobblestones and
sometimes bare earth with struggling
greenish gray vegetation the houses were
tall peak roofed incredibly old and
crazily leaning backward forward and
side-wise occasionally an opposite pair
both leaning forward almost met across
the street like an arch and certainly
they kept most of the light from the
ground below there were a few overhead
bridges from house to house across the
street the inhabitants of that street
impressed me peculiarly at first I
thought it was because they were all
silent and reticent but later decided it
was because they were all very old I do
not know how I came to live on such a
street but I was not myself when I moved
there I had been living in many poor
places always evicted for want of money
until at last I came upon that tottering
house and the Rue Doce kept by the
paralytic blando it was the third house
from the top of the street and by far
the tallest of them all my room was on
the fifth story the only inhabited room
there since the house was almost empty
on the night I arrived I heard strange
music from the peak to Garret overhead
and the next day asked old blando about
it
he told me it was an old German vile
player a strange dumb man who signed his
name is Eric zan and who played evenings
in a cheap theater orchestra adding that
zan's desire to play in the night after
his return from the theater was the
reason he had chosen this lofty and
isolated garret room who's single gable
window was the only point on the street
from which one could look over the
terminating wall at the declivity and
panorama beyond
thereafter I heard San every night and
although he kept me awake I was haunted
by the weirdness of his music knowing
little of the art myself I was yet
certain that none of his harmonies had
any relation to music I had heard before
and concluded that he was a composer of
highly original genius
the longer I listened the more I was
fascinated until after a week I resolved
to make the old man's acquaintance one
night as he was returning from his work
i intercepted zan in the hallway and
told him that I would like to know him
and be with him when he played he was a
small lean bent person with shabby
clothes blue eyes grotesque satyr like
face and nearly bald head and at my
first words seemed both angered and
frightened my obvious friendliness
however finally melted him and he
grudgingly motioned to me to follow him
up the dark creaking and rickety attic
stairs his room one of only two in the
steeply pitched garret was on the west
side toward the high wall that formed
the upper end of the street it's size
was very great and seemed the greater
because of its extraordinary Berenice
and neglect a furniture that was only a
narrow iron bedstead a dingy wash stand
a small table a large bookcase an iron
music rack and three old-fashioned
chairs sheets of music were piled in
disorder about the floor the walls were
of bare boards and had probably never
known plaster whilst the abundance of
dust and cobwebs made the place seem
more deserted than inhabited evidently
Eric sans world of beauty lay in some
far cosmos of the imagination motioning
me to sit down the dumb man closed the
door turned the large wooden bolt and
lighted a candle to augment the one he
had brought with him he now removed his
vial from its moth-eaten covering and
taking it seated himself in the least
uncomfortable of the chairs he did not
employ the music rack but offering no
choice and playing from memory and
chanted me for over an hour with strains
I had never heard before strains which
must have been of his own devising to
describe their exact nature is
impossible for one Unversed in music
they were a kind of fugue with recurrent
passages of the most captivating quality
but to me were notable for the absence
of any of the weird notes I had
overheard from my room below on other
occasions those haunting notes I had
remembered and it often hummed and
whistled inaccurately to myself so when
the player at length laid down his bow I
asked him if he would render some of
them as I began my request the wrinkled
satyr like face lost the board placidity
and it possessed during the playing and
seemed to show the same curious mixture
of anger and fright which I had noticed
when first I accosted the old man for a
moment I was inclined to use persuasion
regarding rather lightly the whims of
senility and even tried to awaken my
hosts weirder mood by whistling a few of
the strains to which I had listened the
night before but I did not pursue this
course for more than a moment for when
the dumb musician recognized the
whistled air his face grew suddenly
distorted with an expression wholly
beyond analysis and his long cold bony
right hand reached out to stop my mouth
and silenced the crude imitation as he
did this he further demonstrated his
eccentricity by casting a startled
glance toward the lone curtain'd window
as if fearful of some intruder a glance
doubly absurd since the garret stood
high in inaccessible above all the
adjacent roofs
this window being the only point on the
steep street as the concierge had told
me from which one could see over the
wall at the summit
the old man's glance brought bland oohs
remarked to my mind and with a certain
capriciousness I felt a wish to look out
over the wide and dizzying panorama of
moonlit roofs and city lights beyond the
hilltop which of all the dwellers in the
brood oh say only this crabbed musician
could say I moved toward the window and
would have drawn aside the nondescript
curtains when with a frightened rage
even greater than before the dumb lodger
was upon me again this time motioning
with his head toward the door as he
nervously strove to drag me thither with
both hands now thoroughly disgusted with
my host I ordered him to release me and
told him I would go at once his clutch
relaxed and as he saw my disgust and
offence his own anger seemed to subside
he tightened his relaxing grip but this
time in a friendly manner forcing me
into a chair then with an appearance of
wistfulness crossing to the littered
table where he wrote many words with a
pencil in the labored French of a
foreigner the note which he finally
handed me was an appeal for tolerance
and forgiveness
Zann said that he was old lonely and
afflicted with strange fears and nervous
disorders connected with his music and
with other things he had enjoyed my
listening to his music and wished I
would come again and not mind his
eccentricities but he could not play to
another his weird harmonies and could
not bear hearing them from another nor
could he bear having anything in his
room touched by another he had not known
until our hallway conversation that I
could overhear his playing in my room
and now asked me if I would arrange with
blando to take a lower room where I
could not hear him in the night he would
he wrote to fray the difference in rent
as I sat deciphering the execrable
French I felt more lenient toward the
old man he was a victim of physical and
nervous suffering as was I and my
metaphysical studies had taught me
kindness in the silence there came a
slight sound from the window the shutter
must have rattled in the night wind and
for some reason I started almost as
violently as dead eric-san
so when I had finished reading I shook
my hosts by the hand and departed as a
friend
the next day blando gave me a more
expensive room on the third floor
between the apartments of an aged
moneylender and the room of a
respectable upholsterer there was no one
on the fourth floor it was not long
before I found that sans eagerness for
my company was not as great as it it
seemed while he was persuading me to
move down from the fifth story he did
not ask me to call on him and when I did
call he appeared uneasy and played
listless Lea this was always at night in
the day he slept and would admit no one
my liking for him did not grow though
the attic room and the weird music
seemed to hold an odd fascination for me
I had a curious desire to look out of
that window over the wall and down the
unseen slope at the glittering roofs and
spires which must lie outspread there
once I went up to the garret during
theatre hours when zan was away but the
door was locked what I did succeed in
doing was to overhear the nocturnal
playing of the dumb old man at first I
would tiptoe up to my old fifth floor
then I grew bold enough to climb the
last creaking staircase to the peak to
Garret there in the narrow hall outside
the bolted door with a covered keyhole I
often heard sounds which filled me with
an indefinable dread the dread of vague
wonder and brooding mystery it was not
that the sounds were hideous for they
were not but that they held vibrations
suggesting nothing on this globe of
Earth and that at certain intervals they
assumed a symphonic quality which I
could hardly conceive as produced by one
player certainly eric-san was a genius
of wild power as the weeks passed the
playing grew Wilder will see old
musician acquired an increasing Haggard
nests and furtiveness pitiful to behold
he now refused to admit me at any time
and shunned me whenever we met on the
stairs
then one night as I listened at the door
I heard the shrieking vile into a
chaotic battle of sound a pandemonium
which would have led me to doubt my own
shaking sanity had there not come from
behind that barred portal a piteous
proof that the horror was real the awful
inarticulate cry which only a mute can
utter and which rises only in moments of
the most terrible fear or anguish I
knocks repeatedly at the door but
received no response
afterward I waited in the black hallway
shivering with cold and fear till I
heard the poor musicians feeble effort
to rise from the floor by the aid of a
chair believing him just conscious after
a fainting fit I renewed my rapping at
the same time calling out my name
reassuringly I herds and stumbled to the
window and closed both shudder and sash
then stumbled to the door which he
falteringly unfastened to admit me this
time his delight at having me present
was real for his distorted face gleamed
with relief while he clutched at my coat
as a child clutches at his mother's
skirts shaking pathetically the old man
forced me into a chair whilst he sank
into another beside which his violin bow
lay carelessly on the floor
he sat for some time inactive nodding
oddly but having a paradoxical
suggestion of intense and frightened
listening subsequently he seemed to be
satisfied and crossing to a chair by the
table wrote a brief note handed it to me
and returned to the table where he began
to write rapidly and incessantly the
note implored me in the name of mercy
and for the sake of my own curiosity to
wait where I was while he prepared a
full account in German of all the
marvels and terrors which beset him I
waited and the dumb man's pencil flew it
was perhaps an hour later while I still
waited and while the old musicians
feverishly written sheets still
continued to pile up that I saw Zayin
start as from the hint of a horrible
shock unmistakeably he was looking at
the curtain window and listening
shudderingly then I have fancied I heard
a sound myself though it was not a
horrible sound but rather an exquisitely
low an infinitely distant musical note
suggesting a player in one of the
neighboring houses
or in some abode beyond the lofty wall
over which I had never been able to look
upon Xan the effect was terrible for
dropping his pencil suddenly heroes
seized his vial and commenced to rend
the night with the wildest playing I had
ever heard from his beau save when
listening at the bard door it would be
useless to describe the playing of erik
zan on that dreadful night it was more
horrible than anything I had ever
overheard because I can now see the
expression of his face and could realize
that this time the motive was stark fear
he was trying to make a noise toward
something off or drown something out
what I could not imagine awesome though
I felt it must be the playing grew
fantastic delirious and hysterical yet
kept to the last the qualities of
supreme genius which I knew this strange
old man possessed I recognized the air
it was a wild Hungarian dance popular in
the theatres and I'm reflected for a
moment that this was the first time I
had ever heard zan play the work of
another composer louder and louder
wilder and wilder mounted the shrieking
and whining of that desperate vile the
player was dripping with an uncanny
perspiration and twisted like a monkey
always looking frantically at the
curtain'd window in his frenzied strains
I could almost see shadowy satyrs and
back and Isles
dancing and whirling insanely through
seething abyss of clouds and smoke and
lightning and then I thought I heard a
shrill er steadier note that was not
from the vile a calm deliberate
purposeful mocking note from far away in
the West at this juncture the shudder
began to rattle in a howling night wind
which had sprung up outside as if an
answer to the mad playing within sans
screaming vile now outdid itself
emitting sounds I'd never thought a vial
could emit the shudder rattled more
loudly unfastened and commenced slamming
against the window then the glass broke
shivering Lea under the persistent
impacts and the chill wind rushed in
making the candles sputter and rustling
the sheets of paper on the table where's
Anne had begun to write out his horrible
secret I looked at zan and saw that he
was past conscious observation his blue
eyes were bulging glassy and sightless
frantic playing had become a blind
mechanical unrecognizable orgy that no
pen could even suggest a sudden gust
stronger than the others caught up the
manuscript and bore it toward the window
I followed the flying sheets in
desperation but they were gone before I
reached the demolished panes then I
remembered my old wish to gaze from this
window the only window in the Rue Doce
from which one might see the slope
beyond the wall and the city outspread
beneath it was very dark but the city's
lights always burned and I expected to
see them there amidst the rain and wind
yet when I looked from that highest of
all gable windows looked while the
candles sputtered and the insane vile
howled with the night wind
I saw nose cities spread below and no
friendly lights gleamed from remembered
streets but only the blackness of space
illimitable unimaginative
having no semblance of anything on earth
and as I stood there looking in terror
the wind blew out both the candles in
that ancient peaked garret leaving me in
savage and impenetrable darkness with
chaos and pandemonium before me and the
demon madness of that night bang vile
behind me I staggered back in the dark
without the means of striking a light
crashing against the table overturning a
chair and finally groping my way to the
place where the blackness screamed with
shocking music to save myself at Eric's
and I could at least try whatever the
powers opposed to me once I thought some
chill thing brushed me and I screamed
but my scream could not be heard above
that hideous vile suddenly out of the
blackness the madly sawing bow struck me
and I knew I was close to the player I
felt a head touch the back of zann's
chair and then found and shook his
shoulder in an effort to bring him to
his senses he did not respond and still
the vial shrieked on without slackening
I moved my hand to his head whose
mechanical nodding I was able to stop
and shout it in his ear that we must
both flee from the unknown things of the
night but he neither answered me nor
abated the frenzy of his unutterable
music while all through the garret
strange currents of wind seemed to dance
in the darkness and babble
when my hand touched his ear I shuddered
though I knew not why knew not why until
I felt the still face the ice-cold
stiffened unbreathing face whose glassy
eyes bulged uselessly into the void and
then by some miracle finding the door in
the large wooden bolt I plunged wildly
away from that glassy eyed thing in the
dark and from the ghoulish howling of
that accursed vial whose fury increased
even as I plunged leaping floating
flying down those endless stairs through
the dark house racing mindlessly out
into the narrow steep and ancient street
of steps and tottering houses clattering
down steps and over cobbles to the lower
streets in the putrid Canyon walled
river canting across the great dark
bridge to the broader healthier streets
and boulevards we know all these are
terrible impressions that linger with me
and I recall that there was no wind and
that the moon was out and that all the
lights of the city twinkled despite my
most careful searches and investigations
I have never since been able to find the
Rue Doce but I am not wholly sorry
either for this or for the loss and
undream abullah bise's of the closely
written sheets which alone could have
explained the music of Eric Zen
[Music]
it's 25 minutes past 11:00 right now my
good friend John chambers said and at 12
o'clock midnight he's scheduled to die
you know why I got you over here tonight
because you're a screwy piano player a
screwy as they come I guess and God
knows if anybody in this world is
psychic or Fae that's what they call it
isn't it you are have a drink
Jerry I nodded and relaxed in chambers
softest armchair as he opened a small
liquor cabinet that stood in a corner of
his comfortable home a large and
beautifully furnished room on the third
and top floor of an establishment that
may best be described as a cross between
a private club and a bachelor
gentleman's rooming house the sort of
place with a reception room on the first
floor telephone service in each room
Swank for minor executives at moderate
cost just the sort of place for a
wifeless young man chambers mix two
whiskey sodas handed me mine and sat
down totleigh on the Davenport across
the room from me he slept by the way on
that same Davenport though no one would
have ever guessed here's the story Jerry
he said sipping at his drink as he
talked I haven't told you all of it
before for fear you'd laugh
I waited instead until tonight whatever
happens tonight if it does happen or
nothing happens at all I mean it'll be
over in a hurry and that'll be the end
of it and if you want to kid me
afterward why that's your privilege
Jerry I want you to let me tell you this
without interruptions it's confused
enough at best and I want to be as sure
as I can that I'm not missing anything
that may be significant so I nodded I'm
a good listener and after a moment he
continued I met this fellow pierced just
about a year ago when he first came to
live here kind of a round face fellow
with a funny little nervous twisted
smile sort of like a cat's Lord you've
seen his pictures in the papers enough
lately so that I don't have to describe
him to you I'll bet he isn't smiling
like that right now though he shivered
slightly glanced fearfully at the banjo
clock on the wall gulped a big swallow
of his drink and went on hastily
I struck up a sort of friendship with
his Pierce right off I'm an amiable bird
anyway and I couldn't help getting to
know him there are only about 25 fellows
living here and most of us take our
breakfast downstairs every morning and
our dinners at night too when we've got
nothing special going on it's like a
sort of Club really everybody knows
everybody else and everybody else's
business - so far as that's concerned so
I got to know Pierce right away had him
up here for a drink as a matter of fact
the second or third evening after he
checked into the place Lord if anybody
told me that he'd done what he'd done
I'd have said they were crazy he seemed
the most harmless sort of fellow in the
world the only odd thing that I noticed
about him was that he seemed nervous as
the devil all the time jumpy like and he
always seemed to be sort of listening
for something so noise or sound to
materialize that never did lots of times
I had to repeat whatever I was saying to
him two or three times before he'd reply
and even then he'd only answer sort of
mechanically as though he weren't really
listening to me at all well it was a
damned annoying trade I can tell you I
put it down to his being terribly
absent-minded and I made a private
resolution that I'd find out the answer
well as it happened I didn't get my
first hit of information from Pierce
direct I got it from mrs. Thomas or
landlady she'd noticed I guess that I'd
struck it off with Pierce and I guess to
that she'd taken a violent dislike to
him she waylaid me in the hall one day
and started in mr Chambers haven't you
noticed anything strange about our new
mr. Pierce I told her I hadn't now she
clamped down her jaws and then snapped
the man positively detests music hasn't
he told you so I can't say that the
subject of music has ever been mentioned
between us I told her well she persisted
practically went into a tirade Yammer
Yammer Yammer
I'll reproduce it for you as well as I
can she said and she was in dead earnest
too mr. chambers that mr. Pierce before
he would even so much as look at my
rooms told me very emphatically that if
there was a piano in the house he
wouldn't even consider staying here said
that he hated piano playing of course as
it happens there isn't a piano on the
premises though I've often considered
getting one of those little spin it's
for the reception room so I told mr.
Pierce the truth that there
new pianos in the building and he seemed
very pleased didn't even ask them to
look at rooms but paid me a month's
lodging in advance and moved in the same
day mark my words mr. chambers a man who
hates music as much as that isn't normal
I hadn't noticed that Pearce disliked
music though I knew perfectly well that
he had peculiarities and I commented
that I'd played the radio in my room
lots of times when Pearce was present
and he never seemed upset also I
mentioned Dowd's banjo playing down the
hall said that that never seemed to
bother Pearce either well that about
terminated the conversation mrs. Thomas
muttered around a little more and then
went off in a huff I merely had the idea
at the time that she'd just taken a
violent dislike to her new lodger
and wanted to express that dislike in
talking to me I know now of course that
she was right
landlady's are uncanny that way
consciously I didn't pay much attention
at the time to what mrs. Thomas had said
but I guess it's subconsciously I kept
mulling it over
I remember the thought came to me one
day all of a sudden that I really didn't
know the first damn thing about Pearce
about where he worked if he did work who
his people were where he came from
anything and I realised another thing
too that that funny mannerism of his
have always seeming to be listening
nervously for some sound that he never
actually heard was getting more
pronounced every time I saw him by
Thunder after I'd known the fellow about
two weeks I began to wonder if maybe
mrs. Thomas wasn't right after all about
him watching him and remember that I had
plenty of opportunity to do just that
for we were fairly thick there for a
while I couldn't help but come to the
conclusion that either the man possessed
such an acutely sensitive ear that the
sound of piano playing was torture to
him or he was just plain nuts and
neither of those notions exactly fitted
the facts either for no man who ever
lived played a more miserable banjo than
Dowd
yet Dowd's banjo practice didn't bother
Pearce at all nor did piano playing when
it came over the radio but any sort of
piano playing good or bad popular or
classical that came to his ears direct
from the instrument seemed to affect him
like the screech of chalk on a
blackboard affects a normal person I've
seen him turned white as a sheet at the
faintest sound of piano playing coming
from an open apartment window as we
walked past I've even seen him cross the
street to avoid passing the open
door of our neighborhood music store
that's the way he was all the time he
lived here normal in every respect
except when it came to pianos and piano
playing direct from producer a consumer
music under those circumstances was pure
unadulterated torture to him the more I
watched him the more I veered toward the
conclusion that he was really crazy
after all then one night it all came out
or so I thought at the time it was a
Saturday night and something or other
had happened at the last minute to spoil
my date and it was too late then to get
any other girl so I went down the hall
to pierce his room and asked him if he
didn't want to take in a movie I was
pretty sure even before I knocked that
he'd be there he very seldom went out I
know now because of that piano music
phobia of his well he said all right and
we took in the double feature at the
Cameo down the block and then we went to
a beer place to kill the rest of the
evening funny about that too we passed
up two fairly decent places for this
dump where there wasn't any orchestra
not a piano even only a machine Pierce
wouldn't go inside the first two places
just stood outside for a minute and
shook his head and dragged me along
until we found the last place we stayed
there until the place closed and by that
time we were feeling pretty good as a
matter of fact we'd both had enough by
then but it was a Saturday night and I
didn't have work on Sunday so we came
back here and I opened up a quart of
scotch and we really went to town I
guess I liked Pierce more then than I
ever did before or since the drinks had
killed that nervousness of his for the
time being he wasn't listening and
cringing all the time anymore he seemed
normal as hell and after a few more
shots I did the unpardonable I asked him
point-blank what was the matter with him
why he had such a terrible fear of the
sound of piano music that's what too
many drinks can do to a man's discretion
that question sobered him up like a
bullet between the eyes he stiffened all
over for an instant all the drunken
merriment gone out of his face like
magic then he began to tremble horribly
the way he reacted was ghastly I've
never seen anything quite like it
but after a minute or two he got hold of
himself to some extent and he looked up
at me and there was the most pitiable
haunted expression on that man's face
imaginable twisted and Haggard and
agonized
like the faces in some of those old
doorway illustrations I'm not
exaggerating when I say that his face
then was the face of a man damned
utterly without hope and still tormented
that's the significant point he looked
as though his torment wasn't over or
would ever be over what was still going
on and on without any end to it in sight
or even hoped for by the holy the sight
of his face then gave me the creeps just
the thought of it still does for that
matter then he began to talk heaven
knows why except that I'd been friendly
to him and the nerve strain he was under
was too great for him to bear any longer
alone sooner or later I guess he would
have had to talk to somebody it just
happened that that somebody was me I'll
try to tell you as nearly as possible in
his own words everything he said of
course he didn't say all this at once
there were pauses and interruptions and
we had more drinks and there were times
when I thought he was going to break
down entirely it was 4 o'clock in the
morning before he finished I'll tell you
chambers he said his voice very soft and
low and without a tremor in it as he
began though his face was twitching in
his hands shaking I haven't known you
very long but you've been a damn good
friend and I'll tell you you know my
name is Harry Pearce there are lots of
Harry Pierce's in the world but I'm V
Harry Pearce well that didn't mean a
thing to me and I guess my face showed
it for he went on
I'm the Harry Pearce whose wife died
last August of a lingering illness they
called it pernicious anemia the death
certificate read she was a pianist a
professional played jazz but she played
it like a concert artist her maiden name
was Alicia castle that's the name she
played under I knew of course who Alicia
Cassell had been who doesn't and I
thought immediately that I had the whole
story
loving husband wife fine pianist dies
husband can no longer bear to hear piano
music as he had heard it so many times
in his home soft and loud fragmentary
bits practicing the human side of music
that somehow missing on a record or over
the radio
poor devil I thought
I felt sympathetic alright the feeling
of intimacy the drinks had built up and
then this confession Pierce had made
that it's so dramatically and poignant
Lee explained his peculiar phobia I
tried to be as delicate as possible in
my sympathy I looked down at my hands
and murmured she was a wonderful pianist
wasn't she I remember she always played
dancing in the wind at the start and
finish of her radio program and she was
your wife he didn't seem to be listening
he just sat there across from me right
where you're sitting now and like me he
kept looking down at his hands only his
hands were trembling violently after a
moment he muttered and his voice was so
savage that I almost jumped dancing in
the wind God how I loathe that piece I
didn't say anything I was afraid to and
in a minute or two he started up again
and the words just poured out of him
Hal chambers he babbled with the most
peculiar pitiful eagerness ghosts don't
exist
they just don't exist and that's all
there is to it especially ghosts that
don't do anything but just play piano he
reached for the bottle of scotch poured
himself a good six ounces tossed it off
in one sobbing gulp that didn't even jar
him he went on talking raving maybe is
the better word it's been like that ever
since the night she died piano playing
her piano playing I can't mistake it
I know her touch her style of playing
the lick she used that nobody else can
imitate like I know my own face it's her
playing nobody else it's unmistakable
unmistakable I tell you and it's been
going on ever since the night she died
whenever I get near a piano sooner or
later I hear her playing not all the
time sometimes she plays only one piece
or just part of a piece and then stops
as though she's been called away dancing
in the wind she plays a lot she had a
special arrangement of it and nobody
else can hear her nobody else can hear
her playing only me it can't be such a
thing can't be there aren't ghosts there
can't be ghosts but when I get near a
piano sooner or later I hear her ghost
playing the night she died I heard her
first playing on the big grand
downstairs in the living room
I went down but before I got downstairs
the music stopped the room was empty
nobody there but Lucas he was our Butler
then was outside in the foyer I asked
him who had been playing the piano in
the living room and he said nobody mr.
Pierce I haven't heard a sound from the
living room all evening so I went
upstairs again twice more that night I
heard it the sound of her playing and
both times nobody else heard it nobody
but me I asked I know the servants were
beginning to look at me as though they
thought I was crazy
I knew they were beginning to talk among
themselves so I shut up just watch them
watch the people in the house the
friends and relatives who were dropping
in all the time to pay their condolences
three or four times the next day I heard
her playing each time I was in the
living room and each time other people
were with me old friends who had known
her well and who wanted to look at her
and to look at me too and see for
themselves how I was bearing up
God it was barbaric the casket stood
between the North windows on the
opposite side of the room from the piano
standing with my back to the piano
standing between my friends looking down
into her pale waisted face I could hear
her playing there behind me but nobody
else heard nobody else heard I watched
their faces and I know to them that
piano was silent yet I heard it playing
three or four times that day god I know
that once I almost fainted when I heard
it
Kenny Coates had to grasp my arms and
hold me up till I came out of it he
helped me upstairs and gave me brandy
and made me lie down for a while I was
afraid to ask him if he'd heard the
music because I knew he hadn't I began
to wonder if I wasn't going crazy and
the next day and the day of the funeral
it was the same music that only I heard
Alicia's music coming from the damnable
piano downstairs
I didn't sleep three total hours from
the moment she died until they buried
her I was trying to think trying to
fathom out the thing to keep from going
wholly mad I knew that it was a sort of
short circuit in my own brain that was
causing the trouble I kept telling
myself over and over that the sounds
didn't really exist or other people
would have heard them
but I knew too that if I didn't conquer
the the sickness sooner or later I'd go
stark raving mad part of my brain was
sick already
I had to keep the sickness from becoming
any worse I have willpower plenty of it
but I couldn't overcome this thing I
even forced myself to sit in the living
room by the piano
hour after hour waiting to hear the
music waiting to see if the piano keys
would also appear to move I wanted to
find out if my sickness extended as far
as hallucination included my vision as
well as my hearing but whenever I
watched the piano it wouldn't play it
only played when my back was turned and
always when I was in the presence of
other people never when I was alone it
was like a devil in my brain trying to
make me act ridiculous strange mad in
front of my servants and friends the day
of the funeral was the worst right in
the middle of the prayer the music began
dancing in the wind again it kept up all
the way through the prayer until the
prayer was finished and the quartet
began to sing I had to bite my lips to
keep from screaming but I have a strong
will I conquered that time yet some day
I won't and I'm afraid that then they'll
find out my secret and take me away and
lock me up as a madman after she was
buried I came back to the house and shut
myself in my room all that night I
stayed awake waiting to hear that music
but there was no music then not a note
it was just as though my sickness had
gone with the people who for three days
had filled my house but I knew that
perhaps it was just waiting for another
opportunity the next afternoon Kenny
Coates dropped in he's my attorney and
one of my best friends I couldn't refuse
to see him I met him in the library
across the hall from the living room
just as soon as we started talking it
began again as always it seemed to come
from the big grand in the living room
and I could hear it plainly though the
two intervening doors were closed
cutting right into what Kenny was saying
blotting out his words blotting out all
my senses except to my hearing blotting
out everything except itself I don't
know how I looked then or how I acted
but my reaction must have been pretty
ghastly for the next thing I remember
was Kenny handing me a drink with his
face as white as a sheet and
over and over good god Harry you look
shot to pieces for a minute there I
thought you were going to fold up I tell
you you've got to snap out of it or it
won't be long before you follow Alicia
get away take a cruise go to Canada do
anything to try and shake off this
nervous condition that's got hold of you
otherwise I guess I must have been still
in a fog for I remember that I asked him
but the music Harry didn't you hear the
music he shook his head music what music
that clinched it I knew then that I had
to get away so I did I turned my
business over to a friend I guess he'd
been half anticipating that I'd do just
that and went to Canada to a little
place where I'd been going every fall
for years to hunt I stayed there for
three weeks I was really beginning to
feel better since leaving the city I
hadn't once heard that fiendish piano
playing then one Saturday night Pierre
who owns the lodge where I was stopping
asked me if I didn't want to go to a
barn dance at the village and some devil
in May made me say yes when we entered
that hole the first thing I noticed was
that there was a piano an old worn-out
upright on a makeshift Bandstand the
sight of it gave me a queasy feeling for
a minute but the feeling passed off
there was too much noise and merriment
and gaiety going on the orchestra was a
couple of Fiddler's a pianist and a
drummer they weren't bad
they played round and square dances
mostly with every once in a while a
waltz and everybody danced old and young
alike at ten o'clock the orchestra took
its intermission and we all lined up in
a row for refreshments ice cream and
cake I was just reaching out my hand for
mine Pierre was standing directly behind
me when the music started it came from
that old rattle trap on the bandstand
the piece was dancing in the wind and it
was Alesha playing no matter how tinny
the music was no matter how distorted by
that god-awful out of tune instrument
with its loose strings in its dead notes
nothing could disguise that it was
Alesha playing alright playing that
wreck of a piano to me alone I looked at
the bandstand and there wasn't anybody
there
not even the orchestra they had all gone
off the stand somewhere to smoke and eat
their ice cream through that hellish
music I heard my dish smash
the floor at my feet and that's the last
thing I remembered then I woke up in my
bunk in Pierre's cabin with a raging
fever
Pierre wasn't in the room and I lay
there for a while thinking and trembling
funny thing but my thoughts were clear
as crystal
I could recollect everything that had
happened since I'd left my own house
back in the city and it occurred to me
all at once that I had never actually
been within hearing distance of a piano
in all that time until the night of the
barn dance I had gone from my house to
the Train and from that train to another
train and then I had ridden in an
automobile and then in a wagon and of
course in Pierre's Lodge there was no
piano I tried to figure it out figure
out what craziness was in me that made
me seem to hear Alesha playing sooner or
later whenever I came near a piano
I remembered clearly that that old
rattletrap had seemed to sound exactly
like itself with all its mechanical
imperfections and poor tuning not at all
like our big grand then I began to
wonder if my own couldn't conceivably
have twisted its own conception of
Alisha's playing to conform to the
limitation of this tinny old instrument
the thing seemed not impossible if my
mind could make me imagine that I heard
Alesha playing it could certainly also
make me imagine that I heard her playing
various pianos especially after I had
had a good chance to hear each of those
instruments and I had been listening to
that decrepit old upright all evening
certainly no supernatural influence was
at work it was all in my own mind I
remembered a story I had read somewhere
about a man who had imagined that a
monkey was following him about the story
ended I believe with a man slitting his
own throat I made up my mind then and
there to get back to the city and
consult a psychiatrist
a good one three days later I was well
enough to travel so I returned to the
city I didn't go to my own home but
registered at a hotel instead I was
afraid to go back to my own house full
as it was of memories of Alesha and
we've had a curse at grand piano waiting
for me in the downstairs living room the
only way I could have gone home would
have been to first had that piano moved
out of the house and I was afraid to do
that afraid of what people would think
and say the servants had heard me
talking queerly so would Kenny Coates a
hotel was the only solution
when I registered I asked for a quiet
room isolated from the ballroom and
dining room I told the desk clerk
frankly that I couldn't bear the sound
of music especially piano music the room
he gave me was alright there wasn't a
piano within a half-dozen floors of me
but I couldn't stay in that room
indefinitely the first time I came
downstairs as I got off the elevator in
the lobby
I heard that devilish piano playing
again coming from the dining room God it
followed me all the way across the lobby
growing fainter and fainter as I walked
away from it I could hear it up until
the instant that I passed through the
revolving doors to the street then I
couldn't hear it anymore I went directly
to consult a psychiatrist told him the
same story I've told you he seemed
interested as hell told me that my
malady was extremely rare used a lot of
big words and ended up by advising me
that my only salvation lay in fighting
the thing well I did just that I did
exactly as this man advised I didn't go
home because of my memories of Alicia
but for three months I lived in that a
curse at Hotel went to my office every
day and transacted my business as well
as I was able ate my morning and evening
meals in that hotel dining room every
day and listen to that ghastly music
pounding in my brain every mortal day in
the week always in the hotel dining room
I heard it not when the orchestra was
playing of course only when they were
silent between pieces but I heard at
other places too through an open window
as I was hurrying to catch a subway a
fragment of dancing in the wind hitting
me in the face from the swinging doors
of a saloon as I walked past even from
the orchestra pit of a theatre God
anywhere at any time
I haven't gone inside a theatre sense
that had a piano I haven't dared for
three months I fought it but I couldn't
beat it I can't beat it two weeks ago I
finally gave up the fight I moved out of
the hotel took the room here for one
reason only because there isn't a piano
in the place when I'm inside these walls
I have peace of a sort it's only when I
go out that I hear the music and I'm
careful about where I go what streets
and even which side of the street I walk
on so that I'm seldom exposed
maybe the disease will go away of itself
in time
I don't know I only know that I haven't
the strength of the courage to fight it
any longer
that way would lead to total insanity
quicker than the way I have chosen
that's all chambers everything now you
know why I am as I am why I act as I do
I trust that you'll keep this confession
to yourself John Chambers who for almost
half an hour had been talking in a
steady quiet monotone as he gave to me
as nearly as possible in Harry Pierce's
own words the peculiar confession Pierce
had made to him in the same room 12
months earlier paused abruptly in his
narrative without a word he rose from
the Davenport took my glass in his own
walked over to the liquor cabinet and
mixed two more drinks he handed me mine
I nodded without speaking and he went
back to his place and receded himself
then he said his voice still quiet still
restrained though I knew his thoughts
were racing it was good of you to listen
to me so long Jerry without interrupting
I'm glad you did for I wanted you to get
the complete picture without missing
anything no matter how insignificant
some details may seem there are details
which may have vast significance
contrasted with others which may mean
nothing I thought it best to tell you
everything that I remembered well the
rest of the story is told from my own
viewpoint it's exactly what I saw and
heard Pierce never again mentioned his
odd confession to me and I of course
also refrain from referring to it and it
was just two weeks later that he finally
broke funny how it came about one of
those jokes of fate that are always
happening and that none of us can
foresee or guard against it happened on
a Friday evening about 11:30 I know it
wasn't any later than that because I
have to work on Saturday mornings and I
was still sitting up fully dressed
reading but I heard this awful scream it
wasn't like anything human I can tell
you it wasn't even recognizable as a
man's or a woman's voice it was more
like a like a fiend screaming in Hell or
a witch burning at the stake maybe it
was loud it stabbed into my ears like a
knife left them bringing for seconds
afterward
I was out of my room and down the stairs
and nothing flat and everybody else in
the house - they were down in the front
hall
Harry Pierce and two men who it turned
out were Kenny coats and Alicia's
brother Sam Cassell his name was Sam
Cassell and this coats were both holding
Pearce by the arms to keep him from
sagging to the floor after that
single-screen Pierce hadn't screamed
anymore
but there was froth on his lips and
dribbling down his chin and his face was
white as paper and streaming sweat in
his eyes they were the eyes of a trapped
maddened beast and he was mumbling over
and over his mouth lacks and drooling
his whole body trembling spasmodically
yes I did it Alicia I'll confess hear me
Alicia I'll confess I killed you killed
you with arsenic so slowly that nobody
knew I'll tell now tell the world now
that if they exhume your body they'll
find enough arsenic in you to kill a
dozen people hear me Alicia hear me I'm
confessing God I'm confessing it's what
you've wanted all along I know you've
won Alicia you've won you've beaten me
I'm confessing Alicia I'm confessing
that I killed you with arsenic over and
over he went on like a broken record
well except for a few loose ends that's
all there is to the story to date that
you haven't already read in the papers
the confession came as a total surprise
to me of course but I can see now how
completely it explained things explained
Pierce's terrible nervousness his
peculiar insanity everything his
conscience was hounding him every minute
day and night through all those months
his life must have been a perfect hell
it turned out that the three of them had
met earlier in the evening dined at some
place where there was no piano and come
here afterward well you know that the
brother demanded that Alicia's body be
exhumed which was done and they found
that sure enough she was saturated with
arsenic Pierce pleaded not guilty on
grounds of insanity but the alienness
shot his story full of holes they
examined him and they put him in rooms
with pianos and he tried to fake the
malady he said he'd been experiencing
all along and they proved that he was
just faking then he tried to say that he
hadn't heard that ghostly piano playing
anymore since the minute he'd confessed
and that only made it worse
the prosecution made a monkey out of him
prove that his business had been
perilously close to the rocks that he
had been inordinately jealous of Alicia
because of her radio reputation and
because she made more money than he did
and that he'd killed Alicia for her
insurance the jury found him guilty in
half an hour and the judge sentenced him
to burn and tonight's the night that's
why you're here
oh there's one point that I forgot
remember I said that the reason Pierce
broke when he did was one of those jokes
of faith that nobody can foresee or
guard against well the joke was this
that same day while Pierce was out mrs.
Thomas bought a piano a little spinet
she'd always wanted one anyway for the
reception room she didn't like Pierce of
course and didn't care a damn whether he
stayed on or moved out on account of it
so I suppose when she saw it she merely
thought the hell with him and ordered it
sent out it came that evening and it was
put in the reception room near the door
not ten feet from where Pierce went
haywire as he walked into the house but
the real reason I've got you up here
tonight Jerry is this it may all be
imagination but thinking back after all
the commotion and excitement that night
had subsided I can't get out of my mind
the notion that just before Pierce
screamed I heard somebody playing that
piano downstairs just a fragment of
music just for an instant and then the
scream blotted it out music that had a
sort of unreal quality to it and so
someone was playing loudly but at a
great distance like the music that comes
across a lake at night like Oh Lord this
is a lame comparison but it's accurate
like music heard when you hold just the
needle to the phonograph record and your
fingers diminished almost to nothingness
yet strong and powerful microscopic yet
full of fury you understand and the
piece was dancing in the wind Jerry
you're here because I believe that I
heard that music that same music that
drove Pierce to confess maybe it was
only an emanation from Pierce's own
tortured brain I don't know but I'm
certain that I heard it
there have been times when I thought
that I was clairvoyant Jerry not
tremendously so like mediums but just a
little bit and if I'm sensitive at all
to such things I know that you're 10
times more so Jerry I feel that if it
were truly Alicia's spirit driving Harry
peers to confess through her music we
will hear her play again tonight for the
last time when he dies because she knows
that I know the whole story as no other
person on earth knows it and I feel that
if Alicia's spirit exists and can
communicate with us it will try to get
one last message through to me to let me
know that it lives and that it is
triumphed I moved uneasily at that
looked down at my glass which was empty
and shook my head sorry John it doesn't
necessarily follow that if you or I or
both of us hear this ghost music tonight
were consequently demonstrated the
reality of Alicia's spirit and naturally
of a whole spirit world for telepathy
does exist we know that and I can see no
way in which we can eliminate beyond
doubt the possibility that whatever
music we may hear might not have come to
us Direct from Pierce's brain at the
moment of death the human brain sends
out strange and powerful impulses when
it is about to die visions of loved ones
sometimes startlingly vivid and real
sometimes speaking or otherwise
transmitting definite messages there are
thousands of authenticated instances so
whether the music originates with Alicia
or merely in Pierce's dying brain that's
a question we can never answer John
Chambers shivered and his face went grey
Jerry it's four minutes past 12:00 and
he's to die at midnight and in that
instant God from downstairs through that
quiet house came the sound of furious
triumphal piano playing it was jazz but
what jazz sophisticated transcendental
playing a strong lifting rhythm
glittering with embellishments and
flying notes that transformed the
saccharine melody into a surging clangor
of glamorous sound not ten jazz pianists
in the world could play like that I knew
and of those 10 only Alisha castle had
ever played that particular special
arrangement
it was Alisha castle all right playing
as I had heard her play innumerable
times at the start and finish of her
coast-to-coast Network broadcasts the
piece danced along to its conclusion a
sparkling shower of notes that burst and
Cora skated like a musical skyrocket and
then the music was gone from my brain
the silence that followed was deafening
for a full minute we sat there neither
speaking there was no sound in the house
whatever we had heard had been heard by
nobody else then John Chambers looked at
me and his face was white did you hear
it he whispered I nodded loud I croaked
loud as hell dancing in the wind he
licked his lips like a frightened dog I
only heard it faintly he muttered just
like the other time you're more psychic
than I we sat there dumbly as they're
paralyzed through long minutes at last
John's lips moved Pierce is dead Jerry I
know it he died when we heard that music
and you're right in what you said we can
never know beyond doubt whether that
music came from Alicia somewhere in the
infinite or from his own poor dying
brain it's a thing we'll never know I
nodded it was a thing we would never
know again we sat silent then almost
musingly and holy irrelevantly I spoke
the words that were to lead us to the
unbelievable conclusion funny thing
about that damned music John I said the
b-flat above middle C didn't play it was
missing all the way through the piece
b-flat above middle C he echoed that's a
black note isn't it I nodded if it's
busted on that piano downstairs and if I
know that it's only been busted a few
days that would prove that Peirce up in
the death house couldn't have known of
it wouldn't it again I nodded I was
beginning to understand what he was
driving at he jumped to his feet come on
Wednesday night we were playing poker
down there and Bob Ellis's chair went
over backwards and broke a black key on
the piano
mrs. Thomas doesn't even know about it
yet we'll see if it's the one we went
downstairs softly for it was late and
the house was sleeping we went into the
darkened reception room Chambers didn't
wait to turn on the lights in the
darkness I reached out and depressed the
B flat at first gently then vigorously I
shook the key up and down the note was
dead the hammer shaft broken in the dim
dark I heard chambers whisper it's the
one my voice was taught unnatural
high-pitched as I whispered my reply
it's the one his voice was quivering too
now as with a curious triumphant
eagerness he persisted than it was
Alicia who was sending music to our ears
from this piano tonight I could feel the
flesh crawling along my spine as I
sought to formulate my answer it was
incredible yet there was only one answer
could be only one answer then my lips
stiffened dry my heart palpitating like
a trip hammer I spoke that answer yes
John it was Alicia